今日はこちらスティです
相変わらず言葉の勉強の話ですけれども
a 相変わらず
僕は言葉を勉強しているのを楽しみにしてます
で楽しみにするのがね楽しく勉強するのは非常に大事です
勉強している言葉を好きにならないとダメです
まあ場合によっては愛してねしゅびてぃ腫米帝者
なくてもですねー
どこかこの言葉この文化に関して何か好きなものを好きなところがやはり
あっていけないとあのダメなんですよね
ないとダメです
勝利の味考えましたかというとまあ今ねあの
てるシャロンの場合
イランの方が
ギランの
歴史についていろんな
その内容を録音してそしていろんなこう質問してくれてですね
bobo それをた濃縮を聞いていますあるいはアラブ語に関してはですね
その youtube 僕の youtube のかなるを見てアラブの方がですね
スダンから
数段上ですねスーダンからあの連絡僕に対して連絡してそして今この方がですね
そのスーダンの生活についていろんな本当に面白い
ひっそり武装その
まあ非常に
んどういますかねその
ブンブン学的なですねもうしみたいな音音にた薄い内容をつくってくれていますそれを
ま今度うちのリンクのアラブのセクションに
載せます
そしてそのるりん灸のその右し通りもですね
サンダーでノアラボボート
いわゆるマーレばの辺りの
まあ東地中海のところの
シャノアール love 事
そしてあのエジプトの
から後で同じミニストリーズや今ロックオンしてくれてる人もいるしそれよう今うちの
web 際に
待ってなってますからだからそのペーションにしてもあら後にしてもその両方の言葉と
その文化の発見がものすごい楽しいですよね
だからまぁ日本の場合は英語が多いけれども場合によっては中国語とか他の言葉を勉強
している人も多いと思いますけれどもやはりあの
ん
文法の本を見るとですね
好きにならないんですよ
恐ろしいその固いルールですね
複雑な説明複雑な定義
複雑な技術用語ですねそれは一切いらないんです
まあ
動詞名詞まぁそれぐらいのその
ておりますか
忘れました jtf 分それぐらいしておけばいいんですけれどもその他のインターン
ぜってーぷとかー
カンプ x 線鈴 d いろいろあるんですよ
わざとはこういうあの
[音楽]
それですね文法の本を作るためのいろんな
技術用語があって勉強する人にと取っては役に立たないし逆にその言葉は好きになら
ないんですよ
それだけ複雑にその紹介するんであれば
なーん
我々は友達にもですねまぁ愛人にしてもですねー
やはり9性があるんですよね全部全部コース細かく説明する必要はないんですよ
こうだとこうだとコーダーからスキーだ気がつきました甲田光雄くせーがお話した
日本語ではそういうふうに言います英語ではこういうふうに言います中国語ではこう
いう意味なす子様座の特徴がある
からこそスキーだと
そしてやはりこの言葉を通じて面白い面白いことだからをわざとこと版を勉強する
ルールをヴォイト公とかその合意表ヴォイト公とか遠いきて高い点数取りたいとかそう
じゃなくて
何か面白い内容ホンダとかポッドカーステだとか
場合によっては映画を見るネットフリックスで何かを見る
トルクあろうトルク事があることが何でもいいんですけれども楽しくやり
スキーになる
必要がある好きになりたい愛したいそういう気持ちでそういう気持ちであの言葉を勉強
するとですね
自然的にその何か
愛してるないを愛してる言葉を聞いてるながらその中でだんだんと声が増えてくる
その新しい言葉のはいろんな構造はですねやはり身につけられる
付けられる
そういう子さんだけなパターンですねだから楽しく
そのエイブな英語その勉強してる言葉を
スキーの
ない僕は日本語を勉強した時はもう好きだからその
でもちろん人にもよりますけれどもこの公園も大きいのは楽しい
聞いているない思ったのしーそういう憧れがあるとしたの言葉その
そのものな自然的に入ってきます
その生えてきた時点で慣れてきた時点で必要に応じて話しすることもだんだんと良く
なる
そういうようなことはちょっと
言いたかったんですそれじゃあどうも添えます
[音楽]
ん
pr
re